thank you very much
for uh coming inside today and giving me
your attention
like i said my name is ray daly i'm
going to be talking about javascript
journalism
the new profession and if you want to
follow along in the examples that are in
the latter half of the
presentation go to jsjournalism.com i
just tweeted it if
someone would retweet it
so let's start with what is news to
different people news is different
things
but most people consider news as text
you often hear people say just give me
the facts
everything else is fluff all i want is
the facts
we see the same thing in web development
people will say content is king
we don't need no stinking ux we don't
need other stuff just give me the facts
on the page
in fact this attitude about news is just
text
was prevalent at the wall street journal
into the mid 80s
they did not publish photos regularly
until that time
they did not consider anything but text
to be news
the same attitude affected the launch of
usa today
they at that point many people
considered
usa usa today is not a serious news
publication
because of all the color photos the
flash
the interactive graphics and color
but now it's generally accepted even the
wall street journal
has photos on the front page
everyone accepts that news
is photos as well as text
and you can go back almo more than a
century to look at these
looking at these historic photos to
realize
that photos are also news
even the most gifted writer could not
write a story
to compete with this photo entire books
have been written
about this photo there's an emotional
hook to photos
that you just don't get in a tech story
we have an expression for this that a
picture is worth a thousand words
and photographs are regularly on the
front page
of any news publication whether it be
print or on the web
or a news app
but news is also javascript
more and more on websites you'll see
javascript being used to help enhance
the storytelling in fact i will contend
from
the day javascript was released every
website
became an app just the people didn't
take advantage of the capability
so how do i show you in hard numbers
that javascript is important to news
organizations
it's important to tell journalistic
stories
so i decided to look at how much text is
on
leading news organizations websites
versus how much
javascript is there so this is
how much a graph of how much text is
there i know you can't all read that in
the back
but the largest site has just under 80
000 characters of text
they average about 50 000 characters of
text
now you all know that that jquery is on
most
websites so you've got jquery how much
other javascript is there
would you think it's ten times five
times three times
how much more job how much job more
javascript is there
than text
as you can see by that chart
substantially more you can barely see
in blue at the very bottom of these
charts the amount of
text in characters versus the amount of
javascript
now i wrote open source program
it's well i made it open source it's on
github
to create these charts or get the
numbers for these charts
it doesn't have to actually create it
and these are the hard numbers that
produced the ratio
is generally 30 times more javascript
than text
i don't think anyone would have expected
that i certainly didn't
even in my job at the washington post
expect there was that much more
on all these sites and new york times
it's 91 times the wall street journal
has 1.8
million characters of javascript on
their site
so as i said i put the program that
created these
uh numbers that pull these numbers from
the sites
in github and github is becoming the new
footnote
in javascript journalism instead of just
referencing something you go to the
actual code that helped produce
the story or helped interpret the data
that made the story
so you look at those numbers about how
much
javascript is on these sites and you
start wondering does that really prove
that javascript is being used to tell
stories
well just the numbers don't but the
numbers are important to tell you
that javascript is important delivering
the news
so let's look at some examples of how
javascript
is being used in news stories
the first example i'm gonna i can't
actually
show is the oldest example it was
chicago crime
this was done over 10 years ago where a
mash-up was done
between excuse me wasn't 10 over 10
years ago but
it was done a long time ago to prove
that the amount of crime in chicago
varied by neighborhoods so they plotted
out with google maps where crime was you
could see
the trends and that story lived for a
long time it just
wasn't a one day story it lived for a
long time
so that was called mashup journalism
a similar one
this is an app by uh
slightly off the screen let me see if we
can fix that
there we go this is the forest fire
forecaster
from npr using maps
to present a story that could not be
told just in text
and i could go over and over different
maps
maps are very common way to tell stories
in javascript
another way you see is the use of
slideshows or sliders in
news organizations websites they love
photographs everyone accepts the
photography is now
journalism they don't all accept that
javascript is but they accept the
photography is
and they have lots of photos so you see
sliders or galleries
of photos and everything just like i
showed you at the beginning
so maybe that's slideshow journalism i
don't know
the seattle times used javascript as a
navigation aid
to get people to the right story
depending on the congressional district
they used
so the story was told in a unique way
because of javascript
lots of examples of it being used in
navigation
and it's not just in the united states
that it's being used
this is a from le mans in france
and they're using here a timeline
and as you scroll through the timeline
of course it won't work right now here
we go you can get different stories
about the timeline for the election and
i think timelines are an underutilized
aspect of javascript journalism
another way is what some people are
calling geojournalism
using the geolocation in devices
to figure out where you are and deliver
you a story there
because of the your location one i
worked on at the washington post was
based on
if you were attending a nationals
baseball game
you got unique stories and unique
information
about what was going on at the park that
no one else got
here's an another example that i think
is
very interesting this is i don't know if
anyone's heard of this study this
study has been out for a little while
but it was just recently updated
these are words that are last these are
words that are used
in many civilizations many different
civilizations
many different languages over thousands
of years over hundreds of
years and these are the languages and
these are the words
and you can actually play the words
and you can tell a story with audio that
you could never do in paper
because you want to hear what those how
closely those sound
those words sound like in the different
languages
now now that everybody in your packet
got this little box are you ready for
sensor journalism
this is a story from
wnyc in new york
called the cicada tracker now if you
don't know what cicadas
are you may not live on the east coast
but cicadas are
the 17-year locus that return so they
come
out of the ground when the temperature
is above 65 degrees
so they created a project on here and
you can go and look at this project and
maybe even build it tomorrow
measure when the temperature is over 65
degrees
and it will get back into the story
incorporated in the story that
cicadas are likely to come out in the in
near where you live
so there you have app journalism
or sensor journalism
now i don't think javascript journalism
is limited only to newspapers and news
organizations
i think anyone can create a story that
is compelling
journalistic story and i think this one
from
google which is a google doodle
let's go i don't know how many people
have seen this one but this was
several months ago it showed it was done
on the anniversary of the zamboni
and it told you about the zamboni and by
interacting with it you figured out
hey it's not so easy to drive a zamboni
as it may appear
and why the invention was such a big
deal
let's go a little more detail here this
is the balance of power chart
um this was for the last presidential
election
this was showing the as the votes were
called by state the electoral votes here
in the united states
uh who who was winning and there was a
bar in the center to indicate that when
you
reached tipped over that bar you'd won
the election
and this is what we put up on the
washington post on the mobile site
and it was all done using an api and css
so maybe this is api journalism
but it was all javascript reading the
json
from the api and producing this balance
at power chart was
all css the other thing we had to do was
how do we deliver in a dynamic way
new charts or new maps showing
which states had gone to which candidate
so we created a node.js program that
read the
uh associated press api parsed it
figured out who had won what which
states
and it went to a series of editors who
then
called whether a state or not had gone
to that candidate
and to give you an idea how important
javascript
journalists were at the washington post
on election night
they sat in the table right next to
all of the editors who were calling
which states were being called
they were the most important people for
the editors to have contact with
and so this created a json file that
then created an svg file that then got
converted to a
png file so those are what we served to
the mobile users instead of having to
put all that burden of creating those
on this mobile site
so in javascript journalism the new way
to proofread
is code reviews so i don't expect you to
necessarily
read this exactly but you know what a
json statement looks like and this is
just
json and the top line is for the
presidential
election and it indicates either an
uppercase r
or lowercase r just typical proofreading
things
do do you have the case right but in
this case the values
after the upper case of the lower case
had a significant difference
in how the news was reported about how
the election was going
so when i made this proposal of this
talk i said i would
talk a little about the academics behind
this and this will be the only slide on
that i don't want to completely bore you
but one of the reasons javascript
journalism is not recognized
as necessarily a new medium or the
profession it is
is because the content of new media is
always old media this is the media
theory that
marshall mcloone was famous for creating
the medium is the massage
or the message and the content
of this javascript journalism is often
text and videos and
uh photos which are people are used to
seeing and they're just saying oh it's
just the
standard stuff we're used to seeing and
not recognizing it really is a new
medium it's really is a new way of
telling stories
okay so i think you can all see
that using javascript you can tell
probably intuitive to most of you that
you can tell stories
that you can't tell with just text or
photos in the standard newspaper
online you can tell stories that are
different than you can tell
with the paper and
as you recognize this there's got to be
credit to this
photography photographers always get
their credit newspaper
reporters get their bylines the
javascript journalists are going to
start getting their credit for this
but something else also happened in the
last six months since i made this
proposal
we now have long form javascript
journalism
and these are substantial stories
not what anybody can say are just
get gadgets or gimmicks or anything else
these are stories that certainly could
only be told with javascript
so the first one i want to point out to
you is leading up to 601
and if you go to jsjournalism.com you
can link to this on your own device and
take a look at this
this is the story of the last 32 hours
of martin luther king's life
as we know the information now when he
was assassinated not all the information
was known
a lot was buried in behind freedom of
information requests in the fbi and
other places
this is a very interactive story
done by the memphis tennessee newspaper
and they have
interviews with people are still live
great photos from the time a lot of
information
this one's from the washington post this
is the prophets of oak ridge
these three people are peace activists
activists
ones and none they want to demonstrate
that our nuclear facilities are not as
safe
as everyone says and they pose a grave
danger to the united states
and so they broke into oak ridge
spray-painted messages about peace on a
wall
and stood there and waited for the
guards to come and arrest them
this is a very substantial story
15 different parts to the story
so i don't know if you know about this
story
this is not only in the standard
newspapers this is an espn this is the
long strange trip at doc
ellis so if you want a very entertaining
story
take a look at this one and you can see
that
this story again makes use of things
that we see a lot in our profession
being applied to news stories
now this is an early one from the wall
street i'm seeing sorry the new york
times this was the bribery aisle
how walmart was bribing officials in
mexico
to get favorable treatment to get into
locations it was in the news for
quite a bit quite a long time but this
was one of their first
efforts of going there
good just on time here so i want to
really point out
two what i think are the most
significant stories
i've seen so far there may be other ones
out there
this is cycling road forward it was
done at the washington post a few months
ago
it is again a long piece and tells the
story of a new writer
and his training and how he's trying to
break into the sport that
has had so many problems and i'm taking
you right to stage four
because the cohort mine at the co-worker
mine at the washington post
worked on this piece here that i think
is
one of the best examples i've seen so
this is decoding the ride so this is
taking the raw data
out of the cycling equipment that he was
riding on in nice france
and showing the map in a very engaging
way
and there's also uh as you can see
an audio clip that you can actually hear
him talk so you can play that audio clip
and here is the actual data from those
devices
and he can look at his heart rate and
see how it varies based on the
terrain he was going at you can see as
you would expect the speed
change dramatically
look at his cadence how consistently his
cadence was that's what they
the trainers were looking for so
this was the typical job of a reporter
go out
gather information turn it into a form
that's usable and entertaining
that can be presented to the public
and make it understandable so i think
this is just a
great piece and
this is wilson andrews who did the all
the javascript
or most of the javascript work on the
piece and
there's a story called making cycling
road r
making of cycling's road forward so if
you want to read about the details
behind
the coding of it it's all there
now let me go to the what i think is the
most significant piece we've seen
to date and that is snowfall
if have many people seen this article
yet
it was published last december
and i don't know if you can see in the
monitor here but the snow
is coming across the screen in this
video they've incorporated
and as you scroll up you can read the
story
and you can see the video
remembrance of one of the people who
survived this avalanche
and
there's where this avalanche occurred in
these mountains
obviously more photos
and then a video here the skier coming
right at you
and this continues on for page after
page
in the first week i believe they had
six million uh let me get the exact
number i don't want to misquote it here
in the first weeks for six days they had
3.5
million viewers of this article
a story that just does not relate the
same way
if you try to tell it in text or on
paper
so again there's articles on the making
of this if you want to go
read about exactly how the javascript
was being used now one of the more
interesting things i found was
this blog about one of the
by one of the designers of the story
he did this presentation
talking about why design manners matters
and telling these stories
and i'm sure you've all read the new
york times and
other stories and you can see that he
translated that story into the standard
new york times template here
what you can see on the screen it would
have taken 41
pages in the standard template to tell
that story
and i don't think many people of those
millions of people would have gotten
beyond page three was in the standard
template
you could only tell the story by using
javascript
so like i said a lot has changed in the
six months since i proposed this talk
and
one thing is we're now seeing some news
organizations
advertise for what i would call a
javascript journalist
this is a hope wanted or uh from
new york times for from may 7th for
interactive story designer now they
could have called it a javascript
journalist but
they used this title and the bold is
mine
expertise with web development
especially using javascript
html and css is required and experience
with
video audio photography and game
mechanics is a plus
sounds like a javascript developer to me
with journalistic experience
now what any journalist aims for the
highest honor you can get as a
journalist
is the pulitzer prize that's what this
is the pulitzer prize
and so as i said a lot has changed in
six months when i said
initially that there was no respect for
javascript journalists or not as much
respect for javascript journalists
as there was for photojournalist but
that's changed
so in 2013 john branch who wrote
snowfall won the pulitzer prize for
feature writing
so it was to me the first javascript
journal
list our first javascript
journalist to win a pulitzer prize it
says
awarded john branch new york times for
his evocative narrative about skiers
killed
in an avalanche and the science that
explains such disasters
a project enhanced by staffed
integration
of multimedia elements
so that's quite an accomplishment we've
come quite a ways in this
new profession of javascript journalism
in a short time
but i think they made a mistake in this
presentation
i think what they should have said by
the deft integration
of javascript not multimedia elements
so
that is my talk i hope you now
appreciate that
there really is a new profession of
javascript journalism
and i hope to see other javascript
journalists
attend future js cons
i'm just learning i consider myself to
be a mediocre
javascript programmer and just a
beginner in becoming a journalist
thank you very much
you